welcome to the live stream Wow there is
a lot to discuss and I know people
probably think I'm only going to talk
about the latest revelation of
revelations with Donald Trump jr. in the
Trump Russia fiasco and I am going to
talk about that but I'm also going to
talk about how the left is sort of
devouring itself over Trump Russia it
could not be more destructive and it
it's it's a disappointment because the
next election or two should be gimmies
for democrats and particularly as an
opportunity to move the Democratic Party
to the left but so far between the left
going at itself effectively over issues
of sjw's and regressives and free speech
and in addition to that the left
attacking itself on the issue of Trump
Russia there's a lot of wasted energy
here that could be used to actually go
against the administration that is in
power right now and I'm trying to report
everyday about what's going on
legislatively at the federal level but
also at the state level three to four
three four or even five states have seen
Republicans actually undo minimum wage
increases effectively reducing the
minimum wage there's so much to be
dealing with right now and unfortunately
a lot of the left is just attacking
itself over how big of an issue they
believe the Trump Russia situation to be
okay so we're gonna talk about all of
that stuff if this is your first live
stream I will tell you that hey yeah the
reason it's called a live stream is that
it's live unless you're watching a rerun
so I'm I'm live right now Monday evening
July 10th
6:32 p.m. Eastern Time unless you're
watching a replay in which case I hope
you'll watch the entire thing number two
super chat is on this is sort of the way
to ask questions or make comments during
the stream you can use the dollar symbol
at the bottom of the chat window that
will put up your comment or question for
all to see and then I will be able to
deal with that question address that
question and hopefully there will be
productive and interesting questions I
don't know I don't know what else to
tell you about that as far as that goes
I am going to get into this issue of
what we learned today from from Donald
Trump jr. but as far as super chats all
questions and comments are welcome
number three any new members or new
patrons who sign up or pledge during the
live stream you will get a live thank
you from me membership is at david
pakman.com slash membership patreon is
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
contributions pledges memberships at any
level are welcome of course I voted 17
gets you a 40% discount off of
membership if you so please and lastly
please don't troll the chat okay people
are here actually trying to engage in
political discussion talk to each other
talk to me obvious trolling and hate is
going to get you banned interestingly
there we're only three minutes in and
people have already been banned and the
moderators have been fully deputized and
empowered by me to ban and and timeout
users as they see fit
alright we'll jump into more of that
stuff a little bit later so if you
haven't been following the latest news
about Donald Trump jr. it broke over the
weekend that after months and months of
Donald Trump jr. Donald Trump's son one
of Donald Trump's son in addition to
Eric Trump and of course the young Baron
Trump Donald Trump jr. has been
insisting since at minimum March of 2017
if not longer that there have been no
meetings with any Russians at all
related to Donald Trump's presidential
campaign over the weekend the New York
Times broke a story that actually Donald
Trump jr. participated in a meeting at
Trump Tower specifically in June of 2016
about a year and I about 13 months ago
effectively and that that meeting was
called with the understanding
that a Russian lawyer was going to be
presenting Donald Trump jr. as well as
Jared Kushner and Paul Manafort
all of whom were at this meeting
previously undisclosed now we know about
it the whole point of the meeting was
the lawyer had dirt on Hillary to be
used against her for the benefit of
Donald Trump senior during the campaign
okay what does Donald Trump jr. say
first about this meeting oh well okay I
you I first my first position was there
were no meetings I admit I did meet with
that lawyer and yes the meeting was at
Trump Tower and yes it was on the date
that the New York Times said it was on
but it wasn't to get dirt on Hillary
Clinton it was to talk about the
adoption of Russian children
unfortunately in the time between the
Saturday statement and the Sunday
follow-up from the New York Times more
information and specifics about the
pretext of this meeting were released
the New York Times went back to Donald
Trump jr. and at that time he finally
took his third position on the issue
which is yes fine
it's true the meeting was called in
order to give us dirt on Hillary Clinton
but we didn't actually get it which may
or may not be true but doesn't matter
once you admit that you knowingly held a
meeting as a surrogate of the candidate
Donald Trump senior with a lawyer
working with Russia a Russian lawyer a
Russian agent for lack of a better term
who you believed was going to give you
dirt on Hillary Clinton for the benefit
of your father who's running for
president it doesn't actually matter
whether you got the dirt or didn't get
the dirt Donald Trump jr. is sort of
defending himself by saying hey fine we
had this meeting and the meeting was
because we were told we were getting
dirt on Hillary Clinton to use against
her in favor of my dad but she didn't
have the dirt the lawyer didn't have the
dirt it's not a defense folks it's not a
defense it no longer matters
once you've admitted that you went to
the meeting knowing that you were
expecting dirt on Hillary Clinton it is
a maze
that this is the defense that we are
hearing from Donald Trump jr. and it's
all starting to fall off the walls at
this point because now not only do
Donald Trump juniors most recent
statements contradict his own prior
statements the statements from Trump
spokeswoman hope Hicks saying there has
been no communication with foreign
entities period related to the campaign
if you go to a meeting because you were
told that they've got dirt on Hillary
that's communication with a foreign
entity related to the campaign period
that was in November of 2016
Trump in January as president-elect
saying there has been no contact between
Trump associates and Russian associates
during the campaign that wasn't true did
Trump know or was he kept out of the
loop both are possible vice president
Pence in January of 2017
asked if there had been contact with
Russians during the course of the
campaign saying quote of course not
it this at this point is a level of
either incompetence lying or both that
we have not seen for a very very very
long time and these are to quote Donald
Trump serious things very very serious
things and if you need any indication as
to how serious this is normally when
something like this happens if there's
even the slightest possibility of
denying that it took place Donald Trump
would say it's fake news witch-hunt
it's a smear job it's all lies Donald
Trump didn't do that Donald Trump issued
a statement saying he was not aware of
this meeting and he did not participate
in this meeting that is a significant
change in tone and approach from the guy
who at any opportunity even when it's
completely unfounded will accuse these
reports from The Washington Post or the
New York Times of just being completely
fabricated witch-hunts that are fake
news immediately this time saying didn't
know about the meeting didn't go to the
meeting that's a change and I hate to
tell you the trumpets are not going to
like this a week or two ago I pointed
out and we've got a
clip about this you could check out the
clip I think it must be about 10 days
old the narrative on right-wing media
has started to change about Trump Russia
collusion it used to be no collusion
there just was not collusion the new
narrative and we've seen Hannity do it
and we've seen who else was it Steve
Doocy I believe did it a whole bunch of
them of the Fox News trolls as well as
other right-wing media people the new
line is if there was collusion it
wouldn't be illegal tell me what crime
was committed if Donald Trump did
collude with Russia that is a drastic
shift it is a shift in tone and it is a
shift in the argument as well and that
we we will see what tomorrow brings
because the last 24 hours
the last six hours have been incredibly
informative and you know did Trump know
about this meeting did he not at this
point it's hardly the primary issue it's
not really the most important issue at
this time this gets me to a pretty
serious concern that I have which is the
left devouring itself over Trump Russia
I'm gonna go into this in the meantime I
will remind you the super chat a super
chat is enabled if you have questions or
comments for me that you want me to
either answer or just comments you want
me to read you can use the dollar sign
at the bottom of the chat window that
will get your question front and center
in front of both me as well as our
audience and I will address all Super
chat questions and comments also new
members and patrons will get live
thank-yous during the stream we've
already got a few but I don't want to
interrupt what we're talking about now
I'm gonna get into that a little later
okay so what's going on with the left
we've seen as we've been continuing to
explore possible collusion between
Donald Trump and Russia we've started to
see the left fragment in a way that is
both pointless and destructive okay you
have those on the right who don't
believe there's anything to look at when
it comes to Trump Russia because they're
ideologically committed
to the guy that they elected okay and as
Donald Trump himself said he could shoot
people on Fifth Avenue and he wouldn't
lose the support of many many people by
all means if he could do that colluding
with a foreign power that in 2012 was
pointed out as our greatest adversary by
the 2012 Republican nominee is not going
to turn away many many Trump is so I
don't really care about what's going on
on the right we expected that
Republicans in the House and Senate were
not going to turn on Trump until their
own asses were on the line which
probably means Trump approval dropping
to you know lower 30s high 20s
potentially I want to focus on what's
going on on the left and there's a
couple different reasons that people on
the Left are sort of in disagreement on
Trump Russia and I want to go through a
couple of those but - let me put my view
on the line first
I have zero ideological commitment to
their having been collusion between
Donald Trump and Russia I believe that
at this point there is so much smoke
that there can be no other explanation
but fire to some degree there has been
too much lying from countless Trump
associates about meetings with Russian
officials there have now been admissions
by Donald Trump jr. and others of
attempt to collude if you attempt to
collude it doesn't matter whether you
succeed at colluding in addition to this
we have seen no we're not hearing about
you know the Chilean ambassador having
had a meeting with Jared Kushner and it
having gone undisclosed Paul Manafort
didn't fail to disclose that he was
working on behalf of maybe I don't know
Equatorial Guinea pick your country
right it's always Russia we've got the
intelligence community reports we've got
I mean this latest bombshell from Donald
Trump jr. I don't want to understate it
it is major even though corporate media
corporate right-wing media is making it
out to be absolutely nothing so my view
is if there was no collusion let's
figure that out and move on if there was
collusion let's figure that out figure
what crimes may have been committed
let's figure out in the cover-up what
crimes may have been committed because
it's often the cover-up but I just want
to get to the end of this thing so we
can move on because I believe we're
better served talking about issues but
it's a major story this this is arguably
a bigger scandal than Watergate we will
see so I'm not gonna ignore the issue so
why do some on the Left seem
ideologically committed to their having
been no collusion and Russia not being a
story there's a few different reasons
there are number one Bernie Sanders
supporters who believe that a Russia
collusion narrative contradicts the
ideas that Bernie was screwed by the DNC
that Bernie might have defeated Donald
Trump in the general election that
Hillary Clinton was not a good
Democratic candidate and that's wrong
none of those assertions are untrue if
there was collusion with Russia Bernie
Sanders was screwed by the DNC I covered
it I've talked about it endless times
there is no reason whatsoever that's
saying there's a hell of a lot of smoke
here and a lot of stuff to be concerned
about with Russia that doesn't mean
Bernie wasn't screwed Hillary Clinton
you might believe that Hillary Clinton
was a terrible Democratic candidate I
believe that she was a very bad
Democratic candidate I voted for Bernie
Sanders in the primary and ultimately
voted for Hillary Clinton in the general
election but she is not who I would have
chosen to see run I don't believe that
Hillary Clinton is any better of a
candidate if Russia helped Donald Trump
write Hillary Clinton is Hillary Clinton
might she have won I don't know I
genuinely don't know the other issue
that's taking place on the left is that
there are those who believe that if
Donald Trump did not win because of
Russia that there is no Russia collusion
story I've said many times when you have
77,000 votes in three states that
effectively give this election to Donald
Trump if Russia was at all successful if
they were 5% six
in helping Donald Trump they might have
swung the swung the election to Donald
Trump from Hillary Clinton but I don't
care about that anymore and the reason I
don't care about it is that if there was
collusion or attempt to collude whether
or not Russian involvement swung the
election actually doesn't matter anymore
because the validity of the election is
questionable anyway and number two it
doesn't change the reality about the
candidates and their positions or who
deserve to win or whatever if there was
collusion and if there was an attempt to
cover up that collusion the 77,000 vote
swing in three states actually becomes
secondary and I think that there are so
many people on the Left who are so
concerned that if Trump Russia collusion
is proven it somehow damages what their
beliefs are about Hillary Clinton or
Bernie Sanders or even Jill Stein who's
got her own series of problems with
Russia by the way which we made deal
with at some point I believe that that
is a horrible narrative that we are
seeing by some on the Left I don't even
need to name anybody I don't know most
of the people and people are tweeting me
I have no idea who they are
some of them claim to have shows I don't
know these people are they're very very
angry with me because I want to follow
the facts and the money so that that's
one side right those who believe that
their their story about Bernie or
Hillary is jeopardized if Donald Trump
colluded with Russia to any degree
there's another side of the left that
believes the Trump Russia situation is a
distraction from quote real issues I
don't disagree with those people I
believe that and I've said it before
Democrats progressives whoever we can't
focus solely on Trump Russia for two
reasons number one if there is nothing
there if you focused on that for the two
years leading up to 2018 for the four
years leading up to 2020 and there's
nothing there you've got nothing right
the midterms come up the presidential
election comes up you've got nothing if
you've been relying just on on Trump
but the other side of the coin is just
as risky let's say Trump colluded with
Russia I mean let's just just
hypothetically imagine that it's
determined Trump knew and was involved
Trump resigns or is impeached I'm not
saying this will happen but just imagine
right if that happens
Trump's now gone you're no longer
running against Trump
you can't talk about Trump Russia
because you got him out you need more
you need more so I actually agree with
those on the Left who are saying the
left needs to focus on issues that
doesn't mean you can't walk and chew gum
at the same time and this is potentially
one of the most you know one of the
biggest presidential oval office level
scandals in 40 50 60 years in the United
States so you you'd better be damn well
sure I'm going to cover it but I'm gonna
be covering the legislation that
Republicans are passing at the federal
level and trying to pass I'm going to be
covering what's happening at the state
level like for example today when I
covered the the minimum wage being
lowered in multiple states by
Republicans we're gonna be talking about
all of that stuff alright let's jump
into the super chat and see what people
have to say here
Lyle frappé has sent a five Canadian
dollar super shad want to learn about
North Korea talk to Michael Jordan Gary
Reed Dennis Rodman confides in Michael
Jordan and has told him some Tings
sending some love from Canada that's
interesting yeah I didn't know anything
about the Michael Jordan angle with with
Dennis Rodman Daryl Dudley has sent a $5
Super chat thank you very much Frank
macwrite has sent the twenty dollar
super chat I will continue to challenge
you on this but I still think the Russia
meddling did change the election without
question it's six months in and we're
still talking about it and always you
new developments they'll disagree listen
Frank the reason I don't want to dig
into saying definitively Russian hacking
Russian meddling sorry theater didn't
flip the election is because at this
point there's so much more beyond that
that I actually don't think that needs
to be proven to make a really serious
case that collusion and collaboration
took place I think it's a harder it's
very hard to prove a negative
and that's why strategically I
know that it's the right approach but
you're I'm not saying you're wrong fill
her she has sent a $10 super cheque
Kyle Waller has sent a $5 super chat a
sub Pakman did you see that Rachel
Maddow ish about the forged document she
was sent thoughts yeah so Rachel Maddow
was apparently sent some forged
documents that were purportedly leaks
from I don't know if it was the NSA or
what and she figured her team figured
out that these were fake documents meant
to get her to report on something which
then of course it would have been leaked
that these were fake and that she fell
for it and very astutely not falling for
it was Rachel Maddow Frank macwrite
sending another $20 super chat I don't
want you to confuse my concern with
Russian meddling with validity of the
election just saying the meddling
changed a lot about how we feel about
elections in general future especially
can't disagree with that fright Frank
that's for sure Kimberly smoke has sent
a five-dollar super Chad do you feel
that Don junior would have had a meeting
with the Russians and Trump not be aware
of it how do you think this will affect
his presidency yeah I know it so Donald
Trump's senior has said he didn't know
about the meeting that Donald Trump jr.
has now admitted to having had with a
Russian lawyer who was promising dirt on
damaging dirt on Hillary Clinton I don't
know you know I don't know that we'll
ever prove that he knew about it but I I
don't know how likely is it I mean it
was in Trump Tower does he really have
no idea what his kid as well as his
son-in-law as well as Paul Manafort were
doing that day it is hard to believe but
maybe he was being kept deliberately out
of the loop Maria Romero I sent a $5
super chat thank you Jason man has sent
a $10 super chat do you think Trump's
perspective of his meeting with Putin
happened as he said if not what or how
do you think these things happen what
wasn't I I did a toe a big P up story at
the top of today's show about this and I
don't I I sort of I don't use this term
seriously but Trump was basically you
know I don't want to say that the
keep repeating that trump was cooked by
Putin but Trump was like you know the
uncomfortable clueless kid around the
kids two grades ahead of him when he was
sitting next to food and Putin's in
charge Putin's got Putin's playing Trump
like a violin and you know Trump's
perspective on most things he
participates in does not seem
particularly accurate so I wouldn't be
at all surprised that the story we got
from Trump about the meeting I mean
listen we don't have to go with Trump's
perspective because there's a readout of
what took place during that meeting
Mollie McHugh who I'll be interviewing
Thursday about this she's an expert on
this issue she's got a great piece in
Politico about the implications of the
Trump meeting based on the readout and
it's it's bad it is really really bad
Andruw Jones sent a $5 Super chat saying
Curt Schilling is is cancer all right
not I have not much to say about that
Jacob Young sent the $5 super check
could you possibly do a segment on
Sinclair Broadcast Group infiltration of
local news is happening all around the
US and no one is talking about it yeah
I've talked about Sinclair in the past
it's been a while they buy up tons of
local stations they consolidate them
they consolidate the message with
national news so that local news all
over the country starts to look the same
and the same stories are being reported
it's bad and you're right Jacob I should
I should do a story about that okay let
me catch you up roll I'm gonna get two
new member thank yous and patreon thank
you so just to catch you up we are in
the midst of what's called the YouTube
advertiser boycott also known to some as
ad pocalypse this is a chart of our
YouTube partner revenue which is down 85
percent since the beginning of the year
okay what you see here is the revenue
chart that dropped at the number two to
effectively nothing on March 31st this
is when as a result of bogus mainstream
corporate media articles about the
YouTube advertiser algorithm which
matches ads to videos there were some
very alarmist reports saying YouTube
can't control what
ads show up on racist videos which of
course isn't true
advertisers threatened to pull out
YouTube panicked and flipped a switch
that basically pulled all ads off of the
David Pakman show channel and our ad
revenue dropped to basically zero
crippling us okay as you can see by the
number three this is into late April
early May revenue started to recover to
about a third of where it was prior to
this implosion and I was hoping that we
were going in the right direction and
that maybe by the end of August or
September we'd be back to where we were
as you can see by the number four that
has not happened around June 25th
revenue fell off cliff and our YouTube
channel is now earning about fifteen
percent of what it once was I wish I
could tell you that this was having no
impact on us but it's having an impact
we have a very long list of plans for
2017 and 2018 for the show and unless we
make this revenue up I need to start
thinking about well where where can we
cut what can we do what can't we do how
are our staffing levels going to be
affected by this and it's really
unfortunate because we have an
administration right now that would love
to see dissenting and critical voices in
media disappear I would argue that
there's no more important time for
programs and channels like the David
Pakman show which is distributed by the
way every day on 200 radio and
television stations across the country
non-commercial stations we give them the
show for free so we are way more than
just YouTube although we are approaching
four hundred thousand subscribers on
YouTube so we estimate that roughly half
to one percent of our audience supports
us financially right now and that's okay
the program is meant to be free for
everybody we want people who can't
afford to pay for individual shows those
are the people I'm doing the show for in
addition to everybody who can afford the
show and contributes and we estimate
that about half to one percent of the
show
currently contributes we don't need
everybody to contribute to make up for
the lost revenue
we don't need 50% of the audience to
contribute we don't need 25% of the
audience or even 20 or 15% if we can
grow our financial support base to just
three to five percent of our audience
the problem that is incredibly evident
from chart of our YouTube revenue that
problem disappears overnight okay and
along those lines there's a couple of
different things that people can do you
can get a membership at david pakman.com
slash membership you're talking about
six bucks a month or sixty for the year
sounds too high no problem
use the coupon code I voted seventeen
with that coupon code you get a 40%
discount off of membership you still get
the bonus show which we do every day for
our members you still get the
commercial-free all-access pass if you
don't want to get involved in membership
no problem whatsoever that's option
number two patreon you can go to
patreon.com/scishow today for the first
time we surpassed 1,700 patrons at david
pac at patreon.com slash david pakman
show even a dollar a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
helps if just 5% of our YouTube
subscribers contributed $1 a month that
means for every 20 of you 19 do nothing
and one of you contributes a dollar a
month we solve the YouTube ad pocalypse
crisis instantly okay and just as an FYI
we are now at 1,700 patrons when we get
to 2,000 patrons I will be doing an
entire show from our broadcast studio
with my hair like this which is a very
very scary sight particularly to the
kids in the audience but I've committed
to doing this because it seemed like
there was some interest in that and
lastly if you ever shop on amazon.com
you can use the david pakman.com slash
amazon link that'll just send you back
to amazon and send us a cut
of everything you buy tomorrow is Amazon
Prime day so remember if you ever are
shopping there please type in david
pakman.com slash amazon now along that
line i do want to say some thank yous
okay big thank you to Chris Dells L who
has just pledged two dollars a month at
patreon.com slash David Pakman show keep
the pledges coming and I will keep the
thank-yous going also thank yous to new
members who have signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership big thank
you to
Shanee moore who has signed up using the
coupon code I voted 17 thanks to Karen
Brown who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership also using
our coupon code and thanks to andrew
stead who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership so keep
those coming I will do everybody who
signs up or pledges during the stream
will get a thank you okay no doubt about
it let's jump back into the Super chats
because there's a lot of people here
with comments and questions Lyle frappe
has sent a to Canadian dollar super chat
asking any views on Sears or Sears
Canada growing bankrupt you know I have
not actually seen anything in particular
about that but I am acutely aware of the
retail industry I worked actually at the
now-defunct Circuit City when I was in
senior in high school and freshman in
college and it eventually went went
bankrupt and I've talked about the ways
in which I could observe when I was
working there how retail was on a
significant downhill path and what's
fascinating about retail is you're
starting to see so like Amazon came in
and started to really damage in person
book stores Amazon is now starting to
develop in person book stores Amazon is
now moving into retail supermarkets
having purchased Whole Foods for 13.7
billion dollars launching this pilot
grocery store I believe in Seattle so
retail is going to be interesting for
the next five to ten years Frank
macwrite Frank macwrite is a super chat
all-star sending his third twenty dollar
super chat today
aside from the Russia scandal what about
Donald Trump's businesses and profiting
on top of the hotels and resorts a
recent report says he threatened to sue
us ga if they move the women's open how
is this legal yeah this is why I am
increasingly thinking that whether
Russian hacking flipped the election is
very very interesting and and relevant
but less important in the grand scheme
of everything that's going on and this
is where I think there are people on the
left getting confused they're saying
only oh the the hacking didn't flip the
election that's like two percent of the
Trump Russia scandal all right
discussions about my economics knowledge
in the chat going on people saying I
don't know anything and blah blah blah
blah blah yeah that's okay I mean I I've
got undergraduate and graduate degrees
in economics but you know hey you can
learn stuff by reading books too so
maybe I don't know anything
Tina Howard $5.00 super chat love your
show you mentioned in the past that you
do appearances will you be coming to
Maryland Tina there's nothing in the
books right now for me to go to Maryland
but we are more actively working on
getting speaking gigs booked for me I
used to do a lot of speaking gigs at
conferences and colleges and that type
of thing and because of everything
that's been going on with the show
moving the show to Boston last year and
the new studio and ad pocalypse and just
all this stuff I've not really been
doing too much of that so we are more
actively working on doing that I am
available for speaking engagements I
have not done bar mitzvahs yet but I
would consider it but mostly I will do
media conferences media entities whether
it's newspapers or TV stations or
whatever
I will speak at colleges I've done high
school graduation lectures I've done
college graduation lectures it's
flexible so feel free to get in touch
would love to come to Maryland soon
Kimmy Pugh has sent a five-dollar super
chat do you think Trump lies because
he's trying to cause confusion or
because he is incapable of the truth I
think there's two things going on what
is Trump thinks he's untouchable he
maybe right about that he may be right
about that given what he's already
gotten away with the cause confusion
thing I don't know I mean it's not it's
not a super sophisticated technique to
lie or at least to take every position
on issues to cause confusion it but it
might be too sophisticated for Trump I
don't know his intellectual prowess is
definitely questionable so I think it's
maybe a combination of both Kimmy
Jason man has sent a five-dollar super
chat asking is there a way to save a
copy of this stream or get transcripts
transcripts I don't think so but when
the stream is over the entire video is
archived and uploaded to our YouTube
channel like any other video you can
watch it anytime fast-forward skip parts
go back to the beginning and then you
are able to save a copy I guess by using
a YouTube video downloader you can you
can google that and there's a number of
those available okay let's jump back
into some thank yous as I mentioned we
are dealing with the YouTube ad
pocalypse our revenue has gone from
point one on this graph to 0.4 on this
graph which is only about 15% of where
it was towards the beginning of the year
as a result we're trying to encourage
people to sign up for membership which
comes with great benefits just in the
last few minutes Kimberly smoke has
signed up for if I may say Kimberly a
level-two yearly membership thank you
very very much monthly and yearly
memberships are available memberships go
from as little as three dollars and 60
cents a month if you get a $6 a month
membership and use the coupon code I
voted 17 all the way up to four hundred
and eighty dollars for the year that's
what we call the Big Boi I think we've
got how many people are on the 480
dollar a year membership probably a
dozen I'd say there's probably a dozen
people who are at that top level 480 for
the year and you know what I appreciate
people paying three dollars and 60 cents
a month as much as I do people paying
480 dollars for the year because every
dollar counts and along those lines
Dwayne McGuire has also
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you thank you to all of
you also I mentioned earlier in the
stream that we have crested the 1700
patron mark at patreon.com slash David
Pakman show
this is lop a patreon the way I think
about patreon is you don't want to deal
with membership you don't have enough
time to watch the bonus show or whatever
you just want to make up for some of
that lost YouTube revenue that's what
patreon is great for you just go to
patreon.com/scishow and you can throw in
a dollar or two okay Kyle Rome
Kyle Rome has pledged two dollars a
month at patreon.com slash David Pakman
show Beck Schneider has made a $2.00 a
month pledge and Michael Flett just
pledged two dollars a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
a very special thank you to a user who
has pledged five dollars a month under
the name I made this [ __ ] just for David
Pakman five dollars a month from user I
made this [ __ ] just for David Pakman
thank you thank you and with your
support I remain cautiously optimistic
that we are going to be making up for
the lost YouTube revenue it is a whole
thing as I like to say that is going on
I want to tell you that also tomorrow on
the program I am going to be talking
about rumors that I have gone vegan that
surfaced after an Instagram post that I
recently made I'm on instagram at David
Pakman I will be talking about how
within 12 hours of suggesting it Donald
Trump bailed on his Russian
cybersecurity partnership we will be
talking about that I'm also going to be
talking about the unfortunate reality
that 71 percent of global emissions come
from 100 companies ok 7 how many people
live on the planet now 7 billion we're
beyond 7 more than 7 billion people how
many companies are there I don't know
100
companies are responsible for 71% of all
global emissions and I'm also going to
talk about how it makes no sense and
this is it's a moral crisis as I see it
we supposedly are too broke for
universal health care
even though UMass economist Gerald
Friedman from my alma mater the
economics department at UMass has run
the numbers and and we actually can
afford universal health care no problem
despite claiming that to have the money
for universal health care we've got over
400 billion dollars to add to that f-35
program the f-35 fighter jets it's
disgusting it's it is absolutely vile
and disgusting and we're gonna talk
about all of it and more tomorrow and on
that note I've got to go and start
prepping for tomorrow's show one more
thank you to Leslie
Noblet who just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership sign up
please get those dollar contributions in
don't be tricked into thinking that
because you can only contribute $1 a
month it's not worth contributing if
everybody who could contribute a dollar
did we would end ad pocalypse --is reign
of terror on the David Pakman show
instantly I'll talk to you tomorrow